hello and welcome to Westeros weekly for
season 7 episode 4 de spoils of war
what's up my name is Maude Garrett
Melina and we kick the episode off with
the big question this is the one you've
all been asking at the end of this
episode what's the deal with the cast
for dagger the cat's paw dagger which
real quick I need to clarify it's not
like the cat's paw dagger cat's paw in
Game of Thrones is a another word for
assassin yeah and then it just confuses
people a lot so now they just say like
the gas flow dagger but I think they're
going to try to rename it the Valyrian
steel dagger just so we don't have to
hear cat's paw anymore yeah but real
quick refresher it was the one that was
used by an assassin to try to kill bran
way back in season one that's one where
Catelyn and summer stopped this guy but
it's actually summer the direwolf who
like tears is freaking the road out
having a mounting pain and it's when
Catelyn finally realizes like ok
direwolves not so bad yeah by the way he
was so similar to puppy still violent
you're vicious
why why did I want to kill brand because
bran had a secret he saw Jamie and feci
brother I did stop winking yes mm-hmm
and the reason that the dagger stayed
relevant is that was a piece of evidence
about who tried to kill brand now
Catelyn and Ned found supposedly that
the dagger had not only belonged to
Littlefinger but according to
Littlefinger that he had lost it in a
bet to Tyrion which means without
evidence Catelyn went a little bit him
and she decided to take Tyrion at the
end of the crossroads basically doing an
arrest on behalf of the the stock and it
escalated in a wall it was a deeper
study said mum or she's like if you guys
are loyal to me and you know how to
ollie uh take this imp and then hop I
wasn't there yet at the same place so in
the book there's a little bit more going
on with the dagger that we do know about
a lot of people get very confused about
the things that we know about the dagger
regarding the books and the show guilty
in the books
Jaime says that Littlefinger did not
lose in a bet to Tyrion he lost to
Robert Baratheon now it was hinted at I
was hinted that Joffrey had hired the
assassin kind of to impress is that or
something
but it was never explicitly confirmed in
the books both Tyrion and Jaime though
do think that this was Joffrey's doing
but again in the show that Joffrey
suspicions never came up we did see the
jagged area or a very similar one in the
books that stamped Harley was flipping
through the beginning of this season now
the book text suggests that this
particular dagger could be a Targaryen
dagger or
like birth from the Targaryen family way
back when a long time ago what I'm
thinking here though is that how did it
end up in Peters possession I mean there
were lies about how he got there in the
first place Jaime himself saying why
would Tyrion bet against me ladies on
family in a jealous right and then but
specifically the daggers made of
Valyrian steel and a you were point now
we were talking before the show Valyrian
steel doesn't doesn't just appear in
someone no I so I'm obsessed with where
every one of those Valyrian steel swords
are and often they're passed down
through family and through generations
so you've got the Talley sword which was
supposed to be passed down to having
Dickon but Sam stole it and then you've
got Longclaw it's all you've got
Longclaw which was always in the moment
family but now John has it because you
know John saved his life and all that
yeah so usually whoever has whatever
house has the dagger or the sword it has
remained in that house forever a unique
thing about Littlefinger though Petyr
Baelish you don't have no house he made
up his house yes so it's very unlikely
that that Valyrian steel dagger was
handed down to him he got to some
special way and that's because we know
the way that he works chaos is a ladder
yeah that came up this episode I know
that you guys asked us a lot of
questions about it why did bran say that
you know that Eric went so into that in
the breakdown that's coming out soon
by the way some of you guys are asking
like oh am I in the breakdown sometimes
sometimes Derrick what's what's the deal
with that Eric and I write the
breakdowns together every single time
and then if we're both available we'll
both do it as much we're both very busy
so I do maybe this and some other stuff
and he does that but don't worry you're
getting every nugget from both of our
brains in the breakdown but that one you
know I think is going to throw off Peter
big-time because Peter knows it so
something that he said in private to
Varys in season 3
yeah brand now knows about it yeah so
what did he try to do he trusts
kids Pechanga give it to bran is like a
peace offering
yeah I think I want more than peace all
right question though right now is that
we were that's being brought up by
everyone this is the lodge whodunit the
big mystery here right because the thing
with this dagger is that everyone is
vaguely familiar with it but think about
the show from the perspective of a
writer right you bring up the dagger you
keep mentioning that this daggers around
and then the concept of who it belonged
to brand asked him do you know who this
belonged to and then later he
specifically mentioned someone very
wealthy wanted me dead and in both of
those instances you had a talking little
finger or about little finger but kind
of went a next to that idea when he
talked about the person who this dagger
belong to so that definitely made me
feel like oh no no no they're opening up
a big mystery right now who actually
sent this bag bran does not sorry that
we can both agree on brand knows who
most likely he knows the the Internet
he knows who try to get you know she
tried to kill him as well but why isn't
he telling anyone why isn't he saying
hey the importance of this dagger is
huge because this is you know who owns
that missus who tried to kill me
regarding my guesses oh I'm still
thinking it's going to be Littlefinger
you don't think so because he's not
wealthy per se he wasn't he was I think
master of coin at the time but he wasn't
necessarily wealthy he had a brothel but
to say a very wealthy person like that
feels like you know what's already
businessman and wealth is not just coin
wealth can be information as well
knowledge is power
yeah and he doesn't become freakin
riddles okay if you had a thing I didn't
get so if it wasn't betting Cersei so
she had a secret to hide from the very
beginning that Ock hasn't really changed
she's still so prevalent and who could
bring down south east through revenge
only IO he's now got the dagger
brand-new heart the information there
you go yeah and I prefer that to the
books answer of probably Joffrey just
because part of it anymore right but
Cersei it would create another reason
why
well here's actually the nice part of
the question because people are
wondering now the dagger ends up in
arias hand is does that mean she's going
to use it if it serves
who is still on her list yeah then that
would be one great motivation to be like
you know what I'm gonna go back to
King's Landing go back again across or
pick up a hot pie and then jab searcy in
the throat but it also would kind of
make it you know how there's always like
these like poetic kills that she does
yeah you know especially with the phrase
for instance there isn't necessarily a
perfect one for Cersei right now but
using the dagger ooh that would finally
make it just wrap up real nicely from
season one to Stephen
sit down season seven you betcha ah I
mean though I think she's going to use
that dagger for sure but I think she's
going to add Petyr Baelish to the list
when her and Sansa have a good old chat
where you been the last six seasons well
Peter sold me to this awful guy called
Ramsay Bolton who was around Peter at
the time I'm trying to add namespaces
yeah and you know Peter has seen I used
this dagger very effectively against Bri
who is supposed to be a huge fighter he
bested the Hound how again symbolic
would it be if he sees her with the with
the dagger knowing that he gave it to
brand trying to win him over and she
just harmed it's right off to Eyre and
then she kills him with it yeah be good
speaking of symbolism by the way there
is some symbolism with the dagger itself
that we go into in the breakdown and I'm
just gonna put a little cherry on our
predictions there about this dagger I
also think that of course when I was
done with it she got to go fight White
Walkers when it will kill him she's
gonna do a little like flips off the top
of like John's shoulders or something
like my gosh well looking laughing is
Needle Valyrian steel and it's not sorry
remembers I got but she can kill really
well but to kill a white Walker you need
fire or you need dragonglass Valyrian
steel which she now has so yeah I'm
excited about that as well the next
thing that we do every single week here
on West Allis or West irresolute where's
the Nosa is the map check-in so we
figure out where everyone was and where
they now are and we've had a few
movements happen and incredibly yeah
well up north the only thing that really
report is that now we got brand
Arya and Sansa all those starts having
the most Awkward reunion yes back in
Winterfell
I suppose Mira oh my god that was
emotionally devastating she's gone she's
out little sweetie I'm hoping that she's
going back to frog town and
hang out with her dad Howland Reed and
we meet him because Howland Reed was at
the tower of joy and he also knows the
truth just saying but we don't know how
and Reed
moving down past the net compassed the
twins where things get really crazy
interesting obviously so this is to me
one of the most confusing locations we
have to identify so you can see that the
Tarly forces who have joined up with
Jamie and the Lannister forces who were
at Casterly Rock they abandon it and
they they went down and they took
Highgarden instead and then they've
since robbed Highgarden of its gold and
grains so they're and they're making
their way along here's my guess and this
is going to be a lot of guessing here
this is the Rose Road the Rose Road
essentially leads from Highgarden up
toward King's Landing now they talk a
lot about crossing the Blackwater rush
so we know Blackwater Bay where Tyrion
fought a long time ago is on the other
side of King's Landing the Blackwater
rush is the river that feeds into the
bay so crossing that would place them
right around here these woods that
actually were burned down I think back
and like season two or something but
that's roughly where would be here's the
fascinating thing about it though the
rush actually has a little like Inlet
that wraps around King's Landing
so the my point is they were crazy close
to King's wedding when that happened and
my thing is Danny not only rocked up
with the Dothraki at this battle but
also on a dragon now if she's over here
a dragon stone and then flies the dragon
as the crow flies or the dragon if it
goes straight over King's Landing so
also if you had to would have to have
done is looked oh but there was a storm
rolling into night if that happened by
the way that would have been the vision
of the Dragons shadow over King's
Landing
Brian has a vision once that means I
think they would have shown that but the
Dothraki definitely went either on foot
which could be really interesting
because that means they very much
bypassed King's Landing or there still
are some ships available so that's
possibility to only other thing to point
out a while we're kind of just roughly
talking about people a lot of you guys
want to talk about this in a Sande
series yeah how there's even more to the
theory go watch last
episode don't you agree huh what what
she my reckons and Sundays a trader I'm
just saying that she's acting weird yes
because she just bought some time and
that makes women gold nuts
yes because he's no longer there they
finally sealed the deal I want to remind
you that Masson day has been around the
block a little bit she's the one that
helped Daenerys kind of relaxed herself
that was in a book signing everything
look at you miss that guy just named
asunder hand and hand Maiden oh uh in
her queen
anyway I I don't know the Musante theory
we weren't really into it last week's
episode so check that out she could be a
faceless man that's all we're saying
also really quick on somebody else asked
about Brian and Sansa we covered a lot
of their awkwardness last episode the
only thing I'll update is that someone
had an interesting point about what if
it's not anything Stan's is going to die
and that's why he's being awkward uh sir
what if she betrays the Starks
my name is resentful I don't know if
bran can feel much emotion right now so
it's hard to read into what these
emotions actually are next though we
answer your questions so this happens at
the end of every episodes every time
you've seen it you jump onto Twitter use
that hashtag Westeros weekly and then
you go hey guys this is what I'm
thinking can you end hey guys your waste
character he's very dense question
that's true I just get right to it this
is a YouTube video though I have to say
hey guys hey guys so the first question
is coming from Jeanine de bean and she
says so much destruction I couldn't tell
did the gold wagon get destroyed
screwing up thirsty paying back her debt
I should watch her weekly well real
quick my prediction last week was that
there were going to be issues with this
ride back to King's Landing so I was
right about that
I thought the gold wasn't going to make
it and that's what you maybe thought in
your question but actually no the gold
does make it all of it specifically
she's not going to have any issues with
paying the gold unless she decides to
take the gold back again a second time
but that's a whole other prediction but
Lord Harley does right up to Jamie and
bran and he says all the gold is safe
issue the gates of King's Landing
getting better thank you
yeah and so they very much established
that the gold has made it through
but that's that whole point about should
we whip the stragglers and get them
through faster which by the way maybe
you should have whip the stragglers and
you'd be on inside king's landing and
then Danny's brilliant plan wouldn't
have worked
yeah but Jamie said that because he was
like they just fought a really good
battle that's not with them but it you
killed them a man yes potentially though
the point actually to make here is that
it's not only about the gold because if
you notice you were listening or you saw
in the wagon there was a lot of food
that was being shipped from Highgarden
they went and took it from everyone in
the area so we're talking grains and
grains burned up like crazy and that
doesn't seem like such a loss except
when you remember that was a huge part
of the plan a blockade or siege of
King's Landing so they could have no
food because they don't have much yeah
right what they don't know is that
winter is here and Sansa is grueling ly
preparing for road all this food and
she's making sure everyone's resources
come to Winterfell so they can withstand
it does he have no idea about this
winter she's not saying that as a threat
at all they needed that food to survive
what is inevitably coming right it's one
of those storylines that you never kind
of care about as you learn about them
words like oh no they're running out of
grain but then you get something like
you know Valley Forge in the American
Revolution which you wouldn't know that
actually that's fine but essentially you
run out of food and you run out of
soldiers very quickly yeah everyone's
got to eat what I notice with this as
well sure the debt hasn't really been
skewed yet so southeast illustrate on
that behalf but or in that regard I
should say but Danny she's wanting to
even the playing field so with that
without the grains and about that
finally we're seeing the scales tipped
back a little bit attention they say
even because that's a good reminder it's
not like Danny has some huge amount of
food stored somewhere either she got
dragonglass can't eat it you can try you
know driving for food as well and
apparently they like kids and people
right and goats mm-hmm
yeah so real quick here just acknowledge
while we were talking about Cersei a lot
of you want to know about the golden
company Erik is going to go way into the
golden company we've heard about them
before on this show by the way yes that
could again uneven the wall that we have
as well question number two that we have
this one is from at built a two to seven
high every save journey with a bran or
Dickon
this is like one of the another one of
these heated debates like recently I
tweeted what do you put on first your
socks or your pants and that turned into
a huge debate on my Twitter I don't
human long socks I wear long everything
but speaking of dickon's we thought it
could be him based on the fact that he
had just rescued Jamie and also that
bran seemed to be preoccupied so we're
going to run you through this again to
properly answer this question so we know
that Jamie is writing his steed like a
stupid idiot but I totally get why he's
doing it yeah why cuz he I mean jeez
word triggered but you have to remember
he killed the Mad King because the
Mediterranean
everyone he sees the dragon he sees by
everywhere like a lot it kills the queen
of the king again it's his daughter but
then also like this would end this
entire war right here take this girl out
make a lot of sense he's a Kingslayer
yeah he's also was great at the tourney
of the hand in the books we didn't see
it in the show I'm realizing but he's
essentially jousting his way toward her
so he's making his way and then last
second of course dragons like maybe he's
way downtown walking fast but you know I
have to get a song referencing somehow
and I said I needed montages and get a
rap song in every time an independent
that would be a good one to sample for
your write songs just saying so the
thing is if we watch closely he realizes
I have in his hands
yeah and someone pulls him out yeah off
the chair off the horse and into the
water so we're like 99% sure this is
broad all right so let's break it down
from where it all kicks off Ron looks up
doesn't have a hole sees one available
and it is a it's a white horse with a
green paddle boom there battle saddle a
saddle you mean also uh that cowgirl you
can see earlier cowgirls don't have lips
you can see that he was wearing
fingerless gloves as you can see the
hands that are groping Jamie are also
wearing fingerless gloves I don't think
it's that common to wear those pushing
Jamie off the horse and the horse that
he was on is the same white horse that
we can see thanks battle and evil
real closely I mean that looks like
brown hair cool brown hair electri is
very much that's why it's 100% and I
makes a lot of sense like emotionally
white bran I mean the side of this
episode yes yay we got grown back and
yes that guy he's basically saying oh
I've got a whole bag full of coin not
enough I want to Castle to my man like
I'm greedy right now and then during the
battle as a whole thing unfold he falls
over the bag spills open he sees it was
hard-earned coin across the battlefield
and it don't matter no more because you
can't spend gold if you're dead
so what does he do he runs along and now
he realizes there's so much more to this
hand saving Jaime thank you haha
and I agree another Jaime question that
a related question you guys had this is
at Jake Lloyd 87 it's probably not that
Jake Lloyd let's chill picture gang
clashes is our man Jake Lloyd INE 7 he's
wondering is Jaime sinking and is this
potential rebirth that he has in the end
theoretically a clue for the azure a
high prophecy hashtag Westeros weekly
let's remind people what these are a
high prophecy hit let's do it so this
one basically was through the Lord of
Light in a way mister Melisandre talks
about this all the time
we always see her burning things looking
through the fire she's trying to figure
out who this promised prince is she
thought it was Dennis because Dennis was
born during the red comet to the Red
Rocks or the sky she was wrong why
because of variables
there's many of them so basically the
whole theory is that there's going to be
a long night could be a long winter and
a special hero the azure high which we
realize this season can be translated to
prince or princess and they were
promised they will be reborn admits salt
and smoke and wake dragons out of stone
dragon stone once any variables and then
he makes this sword the sort of life and
he kind of uses water to make it and it
breaks so he actually puts it through
the heart of a lion still wasn't strong
enough so it breaks he realizes to make
this magical sword properly he has to
strike it through the heart of his own
wife Musa Musa and then he creates
Lightbringer now this is
flaming sword if you saw the trigger the
trailer the teaser for season seven we
see a flaming sword is it big flaming
sword seems like beric Dondarrion so I'm
in third word shanty well people think
he would be a Zora hi because of that he
has been reborn what seven times alright
because I've been to second being reborn
it could be Jamie and hear us out he has
to be reborn amid salt which he had done
he fell into black water black water is
connected to the ocean yes
salty and smoke I mean never drove on
blasting sand fire was a little bit of
smoke or a little smoke and it happened
just in this episode alone so the
rebirth could have happened here so it's
like we like you might be able to tell
we've gone into this theory a lot before
we did a whole video about is Jamie azor
Ahai go check out that video there's a
little card in the upper corner for you
can just tap that when you want to watch
it but you had a Jamie drown when he was
on the side of the stream and I was
running across the water and pushed a
meter and then all of a sudden so here's
my thing with that but I call BS right
so it would seem like the rivers
cavernous which might seem unusual but
it could be so unusual that that's why
they named it the black water where the
water immediately appears black and it's
because it yeah exactly surprisingly
deep and it could have been a trench
back in the day right now sort of a
quarter right anything we know the
children before us are able to raise the
freaking sea level so maybe they were
involved in that so now maybe it was
like the Grand Canyon okay we got
another question now this one is from
under school at sorry on the school Erin
Etsy's ed did Lord Polly survived
Daenerys attack this is an interesting
one because we did seem rather than
getting there with her in the beginning
he reported about the gold and then you
did a few other little commanding things
no soldiers at the side of the battle
all the line that's it mine isn't as
good as you're doing that side and but
then throughout the course of the battle
when the artists are being used this is
where we thought Charlie would step up
and cause the command say the command
but it wasn't it was Jamie both time
yeah you would think that Charlie's
would be in charge of the archers so
where is Lord parley here's the thing
well others going to tell you right now
we don't know if he's dead we have no
idea of that guy's dead
we are not the hackers that are doing a
lot hacking no you guys gotta stop that
and I watch anything in there honey but
let's say Lord randyll Tarly did okay
then there are some options for who he
could be and some of you guys have been
asking about us about these
so first up some of you're like well I
know that I saw a bald guy being burned
alive that's probably him right now
that's Deadpool no this guy had all his
hair burned off most likely but I'll say
specifically that's not the Tarly armor
they got those weirdly bulky shoulders
with a like in like huge bite estimates
of and this isn't that look no no but
then I also had a tweet that came in
from at one proud Indian who you asked
me if he thought that the first bird
corpse that the Dothraki stomped through
was perhaps Charlie well that's just
mean isn't it that's the way that they
write him out of Asia now charlie is an
actual threat in this war he's a very
esteemed character now I thought I don't
think that this would be a blink in your
miss it moment of Charlie being stomped
after being ash so maybe that's really
not that sir guess it's not him because
it'd be too small a day yeah sorry I'm
going to say no to that one yes
now here's my thing yeah if Lord Tarly
did die here's why I think it actually
would be very fascinating they went out
of their way to point out there was
someone in his family who wasn't in love
with these battles in this war dicker
Rickon dick and akin had so uh Dickon is
admitting that you know he fought
alongside a lot of those people that he
just slaughtered and they've got a prior
garden so he's not imagining that this
is something important to him more he's
being loyal to these people
if Lord Charlie is dead he is now the
head of house Tarly and if you're
wondering is Sam potentially going to be
the head of house Charlie it's a dick
instead no he actually can't be Sam was
disinherited that's when he was sent to
join the Nights Watch
his father already kind of ruined his
whole claim the only way he could
potentially get it back is Jon Snow
style and reinstating him
yeah his watch has ended yeah oh it's
what I meant be my king
I meant go die you know hold you breath
a long time and then come back to life
oh no no no John the hassle now don't
forget that I get that you're to you the
next question that we're going to be
answering that is one of yours is from
at so Torrance she says do you think
that Danny's Dragons will die in a
similar way that their namesake did to
mercilessly really great question I
think because we know that in Game of
Thrones names or not having a name is a
very big deal we need to anything well
this is another one that's like
technically impossible for us to answer
we don't know I think it's always more
fun to say yes yeah that's another size
yes let's say that they died the way
that their namesakes died so that works
out really nicely
well not nicely terribly because I look
at Dragons like they're puppies uh but
for the idea of drogon dying because
Drogo died of an infected shoulder wound
drogon currently has a shoulder wound
and I know you're like well you can get
an infection uh remember the weapon is
called the scorpion scorpion poisonous
tip and I was asked for sir do you think
kybun is capable of poisoning something
like this yeah hoarse years dip dip dip
but yeah even if she's pulling it out
and everything's fine that poison could
spread and drag on of course it's a
favorite so this would be devastating
but the two other dragons we've got
Rhaegar oh you know regal laughter I go
write it just a little slight
differences yeah and Ray guy is joy yeah
yeah anyway he died by getting hit in
the chest with Robert Baratheon war
hammer
so basically good blunt-force trauma to
the chest rubies and jewels went
everywhere now let's just hypothesize to
you and say that one of these dragons is
going to turn into a nice dragon and the
night King is going to raise it and ride
it because of the hypothesis very
specifically we all know a dragon is egg
in a diet or beer to be turned into an
ice dragon so saves this one
what is it gets shattered by another
Baratheon hammer and there is still a
Baratheon going around who could make
something like that Gendry his
appointment he's got big enough armed
workers rowing that he could carry
something
that efficiently I think that's an
awesome idea
Gendry is is you know just like a little
mini robber breath as we never saw
robert baratheon in his prime on the
spoke be really cool to see that the
only thing with the eyes dragon theory
is that they're not made of ice right it
might be a cow when the cookie is like a
bone dragon but if it's made of Valyrian
steel it could explode we don't know
directly from researcher have been
spoilers dead Gendron will be coming
back soon to Game of Thrones that we
have not seen the end of his watch
we'll be watching his end whoa all right
let's uh move on to the the last dragon
who had named at the braceros yes
vissarion novice Aryan named after
Viserys hi Brava
was killed in season one by Khal Drogo
he basically melted up some gold and
imported all over his head give you as a
gift a golden crown how would Starks
would you smell your skull melting it's
like when you're using the curling iron
and you burn your head a little which I
know yeah how would this in turn kill
Vissarion if it's the Saint in the same
vein so this one is tough right it's
like well they they dunk de Serre hands
head and just boiling cold not the close
together if we get metaphorical gold
crowns the Lannisters maybe those little
T apparently or someone like that is
responsible for the death death of this
Aryans
but that's saying that all three of
these dragons are going to die which
they're not so don't know baby I can't
have it no but this is again just
spitballing so there you go do we move
on now to the part of the show that we
love because you guys helped make it
happen as well it is called the Power
Rankings so at the end of every single
episode at new rock stars will put up a
link to a poll which you can vote in and
accolade all the votes and we basically
figure out who you think is the
strongest game player miss particular
episode my favorite thing is that
they're never the same week to week if
there's anyone could be I forgot to win
this thing and it's we've only had
different winners I think every single
time into consistent this week is very
different all together someone who you
wouldn't expect to have some political
influence but we'll talk about why
number 3 coming
5.2% its brands doc Brian stark the
average of all the Beatles into one ha
ha uh where why do you think people
voted for Brian because he had all of
the knowledge the only problem is he
can't communicate it yet or he just ran
out of s to give but the thing is as
soon as you tap into this wealth of
knowledge he knows about Petyr Baelish
she knows about conversations he knows
about secrets and that can be very
important especially in war right
exactly so on that exact line of knowing
about Peter knowing about the secrets of
going on in the war and then catching
Peter off guard that means that he's got
more political influence than
Littlefinger does and Littlefinger's a
guy who can see everything consider
every option he did not consider this on
iron right actually a couple of last
episodes we're seeing people who were
shocked for the first time this Varys
was shocked by Melisandre's words for
the very first time and now you have
Peter in this instance but next episode
who knows maybe bran start can predict
how the White Walkers are going to come
through without his information that
could save her from moving into number
two position at 12.9% finally we got
John Smith now there's reasons for this
one as well so it's an interesting one
because John wasn't so active except for
drawing his cave drawings uh this
episode bring in girls into caves going
down I in terms of influencing though
you do really have to think about what
happened in those moments right there on
the beach and there's has her trusted
advisors by the way she keeps saying
that the faun days her most trusted
advisors I really would make a lot of
sense if she's a bad guy she's listening
to Kyrian's
advice when it comes to the strategy of
war and what's not working
yeah but she's kind of like I don't want
to hear from Tyrion anymore and so who
does she want to hear it from right out
of the north
straight out of the dire Wolf's mouth
and she's like what should I do and he
makes such a great point
the one thing that Cersei is using
against Daenerys is reputation and she
needs to keep her in tact and she's
struggling with that at the moment so
she did take it on board he said don't
burn King's Landing she didn't she just
burned everything else all right no
which is a brilliant plan yeah goodbye
and it makes a lot of sense that Cersei
by the way is not on the board
this week because she has like no force
that we know of right now we have to see
what Lannister's did survive so the only
person that technically has more force
right now number one is Daenerys
Targaryen sixty five point eight percent
of the vote I never know why names oh
yeah she finally used her big weapon the
dragon be the dragon yeah did the dragon
you want to see in the world
you know dragon now on I would be like
yay thank you yeah not a surprise at all
that she also leads the kill count this
week and I know that you know
technically you might think what rogue
on did these things the way we count the
killed very specific they have to have
been on screen and as a direct result of
the choices being made by that person in
that moment and the word of the day is
dracarys so without that there be no
flames so technically they're at one
with each other and she he's a weapon in
the way that a puppy's a weapon yes so
big shout out to at hello underscore
Emma 21 because she actually counted all
of these went through it thank you so
much yes the hand turn comeback bran
four kills not bad I'm a skilled
swordsman Jamie for kill pretty good as
well
one-handed by the by mighty not Dothraki
the Dothraki were cutting through
everybody like butter but not our
one-handed boy and that's not even he's
good hand the other hand that's his
great hand yeah oh cool yeah and then
you've got Danny slash dragons with 170
roughly leaves combined on screen yeah
combined kill so like three hundred
probably off screen yeah I we started
this season we're like has anybody gonna
be able to top aria yeah she killed a
bunch of men in the hole all the men
with one switch dip oh yeah fire she
melted humans into ash yeah yeah the
entire force that's amazing this was the
moment by the way that I don't think
anybody's been enough credit to it was
so big and so shocking that we're all
forgetting like it happened we saw a
dragon used in a real-time current war
against men in Westeros I want to just
change this from wagons and men into
White Walkers and whites that is what
needs to happen soon so yeah we've seen
the potential
ice dragon yes by the cloud is spitting
snow and ever
ones like you guys to be a samurai gone
back and save today speaking of you guys
did what we asked and you put ghosts as
someone even even taped ghosts to the
back of your God watches at the end of
this video
under our end card email me all of your
artwork they are so amazing
we will also request from you more
artwork yeah and it will be the end of
next week's video and this I mean you're
the one I want it so bad I think it
basically of the art that you're drawing
for me are all my fantasies that
probably won't happen but I wanted to
come true but this time is Gendry does
come back fingers crossed after three
and a half seasons of rowing no Sabrina
yeah about that he's now back could have
a giant hammer with him could we see
that maybe yeah what's gendry's epic
re-entry into the game of Thrones I
remember he hasn't really been anywhere
where he could groom or shave is he just
a young Bharata like Robert stop hinting
that you wanted to have like a stubble
and stuff and just things you find
attractive
alright let's get on to next week's
episode yes we go small little teaser
let's check out what happens in it and
then predict things you can predict
things too in the comments I'm not here
to imagine then for me and join me or
refuse and die
you need to find a way to make a listen
never stand in our way
[Music]
from sort of night king and his army
marching towards each water bug things
are coming
all righty prediction time because my
first thing that I want to bring up is
my parallel of dew point that Daenerys
Targaryen is now Lord proper tune flash
Sidious because the overconfidence is
our weakness and she only works in
absolutes which we've seen here I don't
to kill anyone we've done bend that knee
yeah dead dairies and she's going into a
surrounding point of view which is GRE
and oarsmen and then we throw a lot of
White Walkers so yeah the episode next
week is called Eastwatch which is where
they've all been predicted to going
which was what they saw in which is what
hounds are in the fire they what was the
episode before that what was it going to
be called so the episode actually was a
really going to be called next week's
episode
a lot of the Dragon which to me was I
who Targaryen lineage episode but I
still wanted that sexual chemistry it's
fine aunt and nephew like everybody does
that anyway they changed the name last
second to Eastwatch so that's what you
think we're going to see hundred spent a
lot of it maybe Jorah goes back to Danny
as well and becomes a dragon rider who
knows my do you remember who is that
Eastwatch yes my flame did Tolman yes
summon flame be a giant bane sounds like
sounds like I don't remember who also
not just a free folk were potentially
headed to you ah yes the hand and curry
because he saw it in the fires he was
like war either white wolf of gathering
at East Washington yes that's where we
going
yup got to go there with purpose so
there could be another crazy great
battle right after this other crazy
great battle we got to watch my
prediction by the way real simple a lot
of you think that Jamie is talking to
Cersei in that scene where she's like
we'll take care of anything I don't
think so I don't think Jamie's back
I don't think bronze back I think
they're captured Jamie I came here again
yeah yeah and I think that's going to be
really interesting to see how that is
with the power dynamic that's what I'm
hoping for at least but those are our
prediction you're on totally going to
climb on in with Jamie out of the
picture
I feel great yeah Jamie oh yeah you're
on fire there you go don't forget if you
do want to get involved with this show
hashtag Westeros weekly that's where we
collect all of your tweets need that
hashtag to increase your chances of
getting on the show my name is Maude
Garrett if you want to find out about
more we want to find out more about me
Lord even my name well done I tried to
cover up the Google it Google mod
because it comes up but check out gig
foam on YouTube as well and get better
subscribe if you'd like yeah and I'm
Phil Molina you know me still the same
old tea boy a giant looks expecting me
what you then hit me up at fimo on
Twitter and we'll have a conversation
about everything and anything
probably game franchises what if it's
like be anything of Jennifers like yeah
what's my mood Rick in John Cena using
the coaster is there a wink in between
anything alright thanks so much guys
we'll see you next week make sure watch
that breakdown comes out real soon
bye bye bye bye
you